ça fait cinq ans
moi j'étais c'est toulouse d'armé il est
venu chez moi pour me lancer l'assaut
final de mon fils ça y met
c'était une nouvelle très difficile
accepter est très difficile à croire et
j'avais la convocation du commissariat
de toulouse alors j'étais pas en france
quand l'armée il est passé chez moi mon
fils il mais il m'avait offert un voyage
en turquie et je suis rentré en urgence
mon fils il m'a appelé il m'a dit moment
il faut que tu rentres
et là j'ai dit à quelque chose qu'ils
veulent je suis rentré j'ai pris deux
avions j'arrivais à paris et mes enfants
qui me tendaient à l'ayraultport
complètement bouleversé et je dis je ne
crois pas c'est impossible qui a imaginé
assassiné parce qu'il m'aide c'est un
jeune fort sportif un homme de terrain
un militaire qui sert la république et
l'été en france
non je ne crois pas maman on est
convoqué au commissariat de la police à
toulouse
maintenant on doit y aller demain matin
et on a fait 700 kilomètres pour aller à
toulouse droit jusqu'à ici et là le
cauchemar il m'a vivo le verset de palme
en rendant commissariat on était séparés
- un commissaire qui me reçoit et ma
famille de l'autre côté et le
commissaire et commence à me poser des
questions madame à ce que votre fils
éternel encore madame ce que votre fils
et trafic
madame est ce que vous avez un fils qui
peut tuer son propre frère
madame est ce que votre fils vous avez
connaissance de trafic d'armes
je comprenais plus rien jeudi mme cyr
commissaire
moi ils m'ont dit que mon fils est
assassiné je ne crois pas mais je ne
réponde aux questions
maintenant je dois y aller à la morgue
voir si c'est vraiment le mien qu'il est
drôlement ce commissaire et monrovia
avec cet accent toulousain que jamais
aimé zébié le vôtre qu'il dans la morgue
maintenant il faut attendre de me mettre
jeudi j'ai fait deux avions
je suis réveillée hier soir et je suis
sorti chua des pistes 6 heures du matin
pour arriver à toulouse et vous me dites
vous que j'attends demain dames c'est
comme ça il ya des règles et des lois il
faut les respecter
maintenant c'est comme ça je regardais
cet homme et je dis d'accord je vais
sortir et j'attendrai demain je serai
avec mes enfants et mes enfants ils me
regardent inutilement c'est quoi ça
j'étais jeune je vais mater trop je dis
mon dieu si vous avez une porte
c'est maintenant qu'il faut l'ouvrir
parce que j'ai tout donné à la france
je suis né un jeune fille de 17 ans je
me suis intégré je donnais quatre
fonctionnaires le dernier étudier sous
policiers
il m'a emilie mais moi je vais pas
écouté cet homme parce que c'est un seul
policier mes enfants alors maintenant on
doit rester ensemble fort et on attendra
demain matin et lendemain mon cauchemar
et comment ce que je croyais j'arrivais
à la marque
l'infirmière et vient et me dit madame
préparez vous préparez à quoi votre fils
il a eu un d'opci quoi mais j'ai
commencé à crier
toutes mes forces et là il m'a dit
madame ça vient pas de nous ça vient
vous pouvez appeler ce commissaire vous
pouvez appeler au prix coeur nous n'a
fait que notre travail
j'ai dit à mon fils je dois appeler ce
commissaire maintenant j'appelle ce
commissaire et j'ai dit mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire monsieur qui le droit
m'a dit madame il faut se calmer et
arrêter de créer dans l'hôpital
respecter sinon je viendrai vocale mais
un militaire qui servait dix ans dans
l'armée tout réussir comme des enfants
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce que
s'appelle ahmed samara
c'est quoi l'histoire je comprenais rien
et je suis d'accord monsieur c'est pas
le vôtre qu'il est dans la marque si le
milan peut être mais moi je vais
accrocher et quand je suis rentré voirie
m et je ne croyais pas toujours que
c'est le mien et je vous confisque
dormait et ravet souriez jetée rive m je
tenais à me jeter mon fils timor
mais moi je suis pas morte je veux pas
crier je veux pas pleurer
je voudrais que tu partes on paie mais
je te promets un immeuble quand je vais
sortir ici je vais chercher l'un sans le
son qui fait sur quel ton médecin
tant que je suis vivante je ne laisserai
pas tomber et je suis sorti aux usa
après l'hommage à moto beau hélas
l'enterrement etc et 40 jours plus tard
j'ai créé cette association
oui je ne sais pas quoi faire et je dis
je vais venir à toulouse voir où il est
tombé mon fils c'était important de
venir ici et je suis parti dans le
gymnase
parce que national imad s'était pas
qu'un fils c'était plus qu'un fils de
fils d'un ami et un confident quelque
chose qui parti aujourd'hui suivi des
personnes qui peut le remplir à part la
fois exclu
et le courage et de volonté qui ont moi
et je cherchais partout il y avait des
traces de son même le son n'était pas
nettoyé et je prenais la terre et j'ai
forte je pleure et j'ai crié toute ma
force toute cette force des souffrances
d'une mère et là je me suis mis à genoux
et je dis amen je vienne et maintenant
voir celui qui t'a fait ça mon fils davy
s'arrêter là mais pas la mire et je me
suis trouvée ou chinoise si je n'ai été
ainsi dans ses quartiers ce qu'ils ont
maintenant l'isard il y avait pressé de
jeunes et quelques personnes âgées il
faut et boston dimanche
et je me suis adressé aux jeunes s'ils
vous plait celle où il habite mohammad
mama s'il vous plaît et si j'allais me
regarde et me dit madame vous regardez
pas la télé vous lisez pas les journaux
mais d'un amendement est un martyr
c'est un héros de l'islam il a mis la
france à genoux madame il mangeait dit
mon dieu mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
face de moi et m'ont tue deux fois jeudi
saviez vous que je suis non madame je
suis la mère d'harry mène la mère de
premier sur le lac est assassiné par
marmara
vous me dites qui mais reste un niro
il a mis la france à genoux serrés
moment-là qu'il était cette année ses
100 c'est un jeune qui était livré
lui-même
c'est un jeu il n'a pas mis la france à
genoux il a fait la terreur il a fait la
malle gamme il a humilié l'islam et les
parties voilà ce qu'il a fait lui partie
de son mystère
réveillez-vous et sujet numéro gars
at-il dit oui madame regardez où on
habite
s'il vous plaît regardez regardez s'il
vous plaît madame on y ont fermé de ce
ghetto il vous savez quand on est
enfermé ma famille on est oubliés
c'est qu'on verra ont fermé et devient
orages et ella et sorties font des
ravages de la société c'est ça madame
connaît aujourd'hui
vous êtes une mère courageuse de venir
jusqu'ici cherché là c'est sans doute
fils moi ma mère et me suit la mort tous
les jours et je dis à ce sujet je le
regarde et les yeux le regard froid
emdeon plus madame la société veut pas
de nous la république nous a oubliés et
j'ai dit écoutez bien si vous restez ici
vous pouvez pas trop de chance et vous
vous êtes pas la charge de la république
voyez cette dame qui ont face de vous
j'arrivais en france j'avais 17 ans et
demi je ne parlais pas un mot en
français et je me suis intégré vous
rendez compte
vous vous étiez ici vous devez être
mieux que moi mais je sais qu'il vous
manque
là des questions là des questions il est
importante si votre mairie vous souhaite
la mort parce qu'il est peut-être
dépassé mais il a raté quelque chose
avec vous que ce soit la mère ou le père
parce que l'éducation
il est importante et c'est avec ça que
je travaille aujourd'hui ces tables qui
nous réunit le soir ou le midi qu'on
peut échanger avec nos enfants qu'on
peut parler avec nos enfants qu'on peut
savoir la souffrance ou la joie avec nos
enfants
mais la table et n'existe plus
aujourd'hui les gens sont très occupés
et nos enfants ils m'ont seul il mange
quand ils ont faim ils mangent plus tard
il ya plus d'heures voilà le problème
la mer c'est la maîtresse lepers le
traité c'est le respect sur le chef de
famille où il est parti ce père où il
est passé cette mère certains parents
qui sont dépassés par leurs enfants
voilà ce qui se passe je nomme alors moi
je suis né jusqu'à et c'est pour vous
voir vous êtes
certains de vous la routine de ma
souffrance mais moi je vais travailler
avec vous aujourd'hui j'ai créé cette
association et je vais tendre la main à
vous mais madame je suis avec vous je
vous promets parce que mon fils il a
perdu sa vie juste pour la moto et l'ami
je suis militaire et je vends de cette
moto tel prix et moi camara et l'après
rendez vous avec lui d'un gymnase il me
demanda à l'ipp pas venu seul il est
venu accompagné et monfils lui dit mais
vous avez la moto c'est vous que j'ai
rendez vous avec vous oui avance égard
toi mon fils il arrive égard la moto il
a même pas eu le temps de retirer son
casque il lui dit tu militaire oui je
suis militaire combien d'années aux
militaires occasion pour cette question
tu venu pour acheter ma moto bras ma vie
je voudrais savoir combien d'années que
vous êtes militaire et mon fils avec le
colère et lui dit sa fille disant oui
est le problème alors je suis né pour
vous tuer mais toi j'en ai mon fils
messieurs dames et 10 non je mettrai pas
genou mais toi vous hadj non non je
mettrai pas je me devant vous tu veux
tirer tir mais je mettrais pas joué et
mon fils il est mort debout et les mort
courageux
et moi je retourne chez moi après tout
cette souffrance il m'avait dit qu'il
faut le verset et le médecin qu'est-ce
qui fait mais ces dames les médicaments
et latifa y dormir et tous les soirs mon
fils y vient maman lève toi ça te plaît
maman je m'appelle comme ça
lève-toi et j'explique à mes enfants je
vois y mettre et mon mari et mes enfants
et me disent c'est l'effet de
médicaments presque tiquement dix jours
comme ça c'est dur et un jour c'était
très fort je senti une présence qu'il
était assis au bout de mon lit il me
tend la même d'élèves toile
il faut se lever mon malaise toi il
mange il aime la lumière et je voulais
cette race et je dis maintenant il faut
que je me lève il me faut que je l'aimé
enfants c'est pas des médicaments
c'est la présence d'un hymen et début
juin j'ai créé cette association à y
mettre pour la jeunesse et la paix
je travaille dans l'établissement
scolaire dans les prisons avec les
parents et les enfants dans les foyers
j'ai créé des projets aussi pour sortait
six jeunes de quartiers des projets
éducatifs
alors je vous demande à vous
comme j'ai fait moi malgré cette
souffrance j'ai créé cette association
est de ramener sept combats pas une mère
comme moi la souffrance que j'ai je la
souhaite à personne je la souhaite à
personne
alors je vais pas voir une autre mère
souffrir comme moi je veux pas avoir un
autre meira alors je vous demande à vous
monsieur d'1 5% à données la société
chacun de vous si vous donnez des 5%
je vous assure que la france il te
restera parce que l'état cela n'arrivera
pas alors chacun de nous s'il vous plaît
monsieur je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]